thank you for the lovely introduction
and
a big hello to everyone out there i'm
i'm coming to you from australia and i'm
definitely really excited to present why
does building a robust automation
framework matter
so i guess you know why does automation
framework architecture matter now many
arguments could be made about the order
of these but from the top we've got
accommodate team skill sets so you know
we want to build a framework that should
enable our most technical but also our
least technical team members to be
efficient automation engineers
we want it to be easy to maintain and
update over time we want low complexity
code that is not intimidating to fresh
eyes we want to enable best practice and
iterations on the framework both the
architecture and code with ease
and we want a consistent architecture
approach that also supports things like
training pair programming skilling up
even across teams and finally we want
low code and easy to reuse we want to
spend less time doing code and more time
doing automation
so a little bit on the importance of
proof of concepting so
you know we want to understand supported
features you know does it support
iframes for example so this is really
getting the idea out there of you know
let's let's try and do a little bit of a
proof of concept of our framework before
we actually decide on a solution and
this is about you know looking at
different opportunities you know
different frameworks different
architectures you know things like
building team buy-in this is something
you can actually develop from a proof of
concept you bring everyone in the team
into it you get as many opinions as
possible you get your best engineers in
the room and you really start having
those stimulating discussions which we
all know get very passionate when it
comes to automation
some frameworks you know they actually
cater to certain software better you
know do you have long forms in your
application again do you have iframes
these are the sorts of considerations
you have to make when you're actually
picking your framework
this is one that could be debatable
architectural discussions you know
something i really love to do is
actually stimulate architecture
discussions as part of the proof of
concept really get that kind of thought
process happening as our proof of
concept forms we actually start to think
of the architecture we'll use now in our
sort of solution we go with in the end
finally you know quick wins generate
momentum and that's the thing right like
as a proof of concept you can actually
prove it out you can kick some goals you
can start to really develop a sort of
message of a success and where this
automation framework is going to go some
of the benefits the team are going to
see
and then finally measure and review you
know which is actually
choosing the framework that you go
forward with you know you maybe you've
done two proof of concepts and you've
proved out the benefits you've you've
noticed which ones it's going to work
with well which system it's going to
work well with and you actually pick the
system
so
you know one of the keys for our proof
of concept and and how we came up with
this robust automation framework we're
going to talk about very shortly is that
we brought the team on the journey you
know we discussed team white as a group
what was important to our automation
framework architecture i remember i was
in my first month at bunnings and i
literally invited i said to the top test
engineering lead i said who are the top
engineers in the company i want them to
be the most passionate people in these
meetings where we discuss architecture
and our proof of concept i want them to
challenge us on everything we set out
with a goal to make the architecture so
generic we could replace the underlying
framework and i'll explain what i mean
there but really what we're trying to do
is create a framework that was again
easy to use for our most technical and
our least technical but our best
technical people could really engineer
the framework and engineer the
improvements but that our least
technical could not only build their
knowledge and learn the framework but be
efficient automation engineers from the
get-go and we'll speak to that more as
well
as i said we invited the top engineers
in the team to a team's channel as well
and we asked that they actually review
all our proof of concept pull requests
and we told them to go hard we said you
know if you don't like the code if you
don't like the architecture tell us
let's have a meeting let's pair a
program on it we want to get the best
possible proof of concept we can get out
of this
at the end of the at the end of the poc
and then we've performed multiple
iterations of showcases meetings hair
programming and code review to refine
our framework architecture and something
i really want to highlight there is
showcases incredibly important just like
this presentation right now it's about
constantly bringing the team on the
journey showing the team your wins what
are you doing what's the architecture
who's in on this because ultimately
that's what's going to really lead to
momentum as you build out your framework
with the team later
so
here's something we decided to use
cucumber so we didn't use cucumber
because of the bdd benefits you know if
we talked to the founder of cucumber and
told that person why we use cucumber
they'd probably throw up it's not
something that was originally intended
for cucumber we actually used cucumber
to enable generic architecture for two
key reasons we wanted a shorter learning
curve so we could actually reduce
duplication of code and have generic
step definitions that could work across
any feature or functionality any
interaction or assertion
and then we wanted strong collaboration
so we actually wanted developers and
testers to both contribute to this
framework
and finally we have a large practice at
bunnings and as i say we have a broad
skill levels from someone that's never
done automation to someone who's done a
lot of automation and comes from a very
extensive engineering background and we
wanted to build a framework that enabled
both and cucumber definitely allowed us
to do that and i'll show you how soon
so the original proof of concept we
actually put together
was cyprus verse playwright and i've
just added a few videos out of fear that
um potentially running both the
frameworks at the same time during a
live presentation might be a dangerous
idea so all the all those demos and the
code is all in the slide pack just for
safety really but um
as you can see the proof of concept is
just basically running through the
bunnings website
that one's in cyprus which took 19.39
seconds just your basic end-to-end
scenario that logs into an account
pretty much standard across most web
applications these days and then on the
other side playwright and
right away you can actually see
something really interesting there which
is
the cypress one is a lot slower and for
those that have used both and those that
understand the architecture and how
cyprus works it's really got a lot to do
with those network requests being
completed you know when we started
automation at bunnings and we were
really starting from scratch you know we
were just automating against the uat
environment just to get this proof of
concept up yeah we wanted to focus on
local host automation and mock servers
and all that great stuff as well but we
just wanted to get a starting point to
build this framework but as you can see
from two proof of concepts just on time
taken alone we can pretty much see that
playwright might be a better option for
the bunnings website because the
bunnings website has a lot of network
requests and because cyprus awaits those
network requests that simple test is
double the time which is really
interesting
so what's so special about this poc
though i mean everyone's done a pop
right well the answer is the framework
architecture was the exact
same
and i want to show you how
so on the left you've got playwright on
the right you've got selenium and
they're the exact same framework so
basically you've got one that's cucumber
selenium and typescript and then the
other one you've got cucumber playwright
and typescript and thanks to cucumber
and that use of generic step definitions
what we can actually build is using a
lot of object orientated design
principles is the exact same
architecture in both obviously
substituting out
what's required to start playwright and
what's required to start selenium and
we'll dig into that in a second as well
so as you can see we basically have the
exact same cucumber scenario for our
home page
and then we have our exact same code
instead and you'll notice there's only
really one difference here and it's in
the playwright test we're passing page
because basically playwright runs off
the browser context and page whereas
selenium as many of you will definitely
know runs off that driver but as you can
see the architecture of the step is the
exact same there's no code difference
except for passing of the page and the
driver
then you go to the support function
where we actually navigate to page and
again you can see we're actually got the
exact same code again so we're basically
bringing in that page or that driver for
selenium
we're determining our host
we're passing in our host which
determines our url
and then you'll notice again that
difference
in playwright we're using page.goto
which is the sort of default function to
navigate
and in selenium we're using driver.get
right so basically there's two
differences but the architecture of the
framework
is the exact same still at this point
let's keep moving through the code
so let's go to the last bit of this test
so we've got our package.json so where
we actually kick off the actual tests
themselves
and once again you'll see they're pretty
much exactly the same in fact you could
have this be the exact same i left the
common config file in one and one
doesn't and that's just because one was
right designed for windows and one was
designed for mac
but generally speaking they run the
exact same
executable commands and i'll show you
how all this works very soon that's when
we're really going to dig into the code
and see how this all ties together
but what i want to stress you at this
point is what was very unique about our
proof of concept was that it was the
exact same code exact same architecture
running the exact same test
the only difference was one had
playwright and one had selenium
finally what was the difference because
obviously there was a difference right
and again i just wanted to show you that
that's in our initialize so basically
we initialize the actual
framework on runtime
obviously for playwright we have to set
up that browser that context and that
page
whereas in selenium we need to set up
that driver and that's the only
difference so that init function is
literally the only thing that's actually
different between both those frameworks
and
the use of obviously page.goto and
driver.navigate etc
okay so what did we discover for our
proof of concept
so
we discovered a lot so we discovered
things like
about cross-origin capability with
cyprus being quite complex you know
navigating between different urls i'm
external of the eg the actual main web
application
you know we discovered that there wasn't
great iframe support you know you could
use some external libraries in cyprus
but it wasn't native to cyprus itself
and that's totally understandable with
the underlying architecture of cyprus
you know underlying files weren't native
in cyprus and i just got to take a pause
here because generally speaking when we
went into this proof of concept everyone
thought cyprus was going to be a clear
winner like playwright this was over 10
months ago right so we thought you know
playwright's so new barely anyone seems
to even be talking about it yet
everyone's loving cypress you know we'd
all use cypress a little bit and we're
really excited to explore it more and
use it more in depth
but this proof of concept completely
changed our minds and again it goes back
to things like you know that automatic
await network response completion with
cyprus you know really wasn't the right
candidate for the bunnings website which
had a lot of slow responses
um you know that that issues you know
things like no need for scroll on long
forms in playwright you know cyprus is
really good at that as well but we
noticed when we had we did this in
selenium because keep in mind we did
this across selenium playwright and
cyprus selenium was pretty much off
right away because unfortunately it
still has those issues with scroll that
we all know about on long forms and
while we know we can get around those
with a few scroll twos and a few
different ways to do it uh it's it's
just flawless in playwright and and that
really surprised us but again it was
also flawless in cyprus that so it
wasn't that wasn't the clear winner um
for us really
it just came down to the fact that the
bunnings website had a lot of internal
iframes so hidden iframes and cypress
did not deal well with that like we had
to do a lot of sort of
hacks if you will to actually get this
framework up and running in our website
using cyprus and that didn't seem like a
good thing if we were only in the proof
of concept on top of that
those network requests as i keep going
back to it it was so important because
it basically showed that every test was
going to be running a lot slower on top
of that playwright had really good
support for safari which is something
our customers use a lot
um it also was really flawless when it
came to parallel browsers particularly
on our local host
um so needless to say our outcome was
and it surprised us all that cucumber
playwright and typescript
was actually the framework that we would
go forward with it was the clear winner
uh much to the shock of all of us indeed
so how did we build this framework
architecture you know what ood
principles helped us build our robust
automation architecture
so
we leveraged a mixture of oed principles
in our design and it really started with
how we initialized cucumber world so
for those that haven't heard of cucumber
world it's actually a really interesting
stuff so
basically when you use cucumber you can
also introduce this concept of cucumber
world which is within the in the actual
cucumber framework and what it enables
you to do is it actually enables you to
pass segregated global configuration
between scenarios
so i don't know about you but definitely
in my early days as a qa i would define
global variables and potentially set
those global variables throughout my
automation suite
well that was obviously dangerous right
because if i was running multiple tests
in parallel that set that global
variable at the same time it might cause
a test to be on my actual test suite to
be unstable so with cucumber world you
can actually pass
all these all these all these segregated
global configurations all at the same
time so you can be setting that global
variable in every test running in
parallel and it's going to pass because
it's completely segregated so highly
recommend if you're out there and you're
using cucumber
to look into cucumber world because
you'll see the benefits of it throughout
this this sort of presentation
so as you can see where do we start you
know we start now hooks right that's
kind of where the automation framework
will always start when you're using
cucumber that before hook so in cucumber
you know you've got your before you've
got your after you've got your before
all and your after all and as they say
basically this code will execute before
your scenario before all your scenarios
after your scenario or after all your
scenarios and as you can see here we've
got our before so this is actually going
to execute before every single scenario
so what do we do we basically console
log out running the cucumber scenarios
just for a nicety
and then we set our context options and
as you'll see there we're actually
leveraging playwright so this is a minor
change to the architecture that's
different because playwright offers you
the ability to video record for each
scenario which is really cool
and then we actually initialize cucumber
world
so this enables us to actually create
our new browser context and page before
every test now
that was really challenging to work out
when this this this framework was first
worked on
and it's because there was limited
playwright document documentation in
those days particularly for cucumber
don't get me wrong you could google you
know
cucumber playwright typescript framework
and it would show you how to connect a
basic test
but there was nothing online for how to
use cucumber world with playwright so we
literally had to figure this out for
ourselves by digging into the actual
playwright framework and working out how
we could basically segregate the browser
context and page so then we could
actually fully leverage cucumber and
cucumber world so this is actually
really cool stuff
but as you can see as we initialize we
basically close any existing browser
context and page that might exist
we open that new browser we create that
new browser context and we create that
new page and we return a screen object
that basically will be available
throughout our entire cucumber scenario
but again i want to stress this because
we're using cucumber world and because
we're using playwright we're in this
beautiful scenario right now and we've
barely kicked off this framework where
we've got segregated global
configuration and we've got segregated
browser context and page per browser so
nothing shared you've got a perfectly
self-contained test
on every test
whether it's running one at a time two
at a time five at a time twenty at a
time everything's contained within its
own scenario so we're off to an awesome
start
all right now we go ahead and determine
our browser so
playwright in those days um really
really the main support was for chromium
firefox and webkit
which is actually amazing because you
know for those of us that use selenium a
lot as well you know that some
safari binary isn't quite as good as
webkit in that webkit will give you
parallel browsers from the get-go you
know we'll give you headless mode from
the get-go
and then obviously chromium and firefox
are great binaries as well and obviously
really representative of the latest
chrome and firefox browsers but
basically what this function does
and as you can imagine and keep this in
your mind could work with any framework
it's basically an allowing us to pass an
environment variable which we'll show a
bit more as well soon
of either our chromium firefox or webkit
and that will determine what our actual
automation framework what the browser is
that we will run on
so next we actually leverage our
index.tx to execute a runtime in source
via the cucumber js
and this was one of the most complex
parts of setup
since the cucumber js with additional
customization is actually not designed
to work with typescript just yet so
let me explain a bit more
so the cucumber js as it sounds is very
well designed for javascript it's not
very well designed for typescript now
that won't hurt you if you're doing a
automation framework using cucumber
without cucumber world once again or
without wanting to customize your
cucumber js runtime arguments you'll get
away with it but if you want to actually
update those arguments unfortunately you
are going to need to come up with a
solution that converts your ts files
into js files
so the cucumber the index basically
which will contain your custom cucumber
js runtime arguments
will execute and i'll show you that in
the next slide because obviously there's
a bit there but basically it works
beautifully you just have to convert it
to javascript to really get the full
benefits and unlock the full benefits of
the cucumber js so
as you can see some minor work done in
our package json to basically introduce
babel so for those that haven't heard of
babel it basically allows you to convert
your
ts files into js so it converts
typescript to javascript pops it in a
file of your choosing as you can see
here into the disk folder
and then you'll basically find all the
ts that we've done as part of our
typescript framework converted over to
js including our index.ts
which for those that do a lot of
typescript will know is that first
initialized file called so if you if you
initialize source
it's actually going to look for an
index.ts by default and if that contains
your cucumber run type arguments that's
what's going to be executed
so let's look at that so i don't want to
over over confuse
so let's see how it really looks so we
used babel as i said to compile our
typescript to javascript on runtime so
we could use and and then customize the
cucumber js to enable us to leverage
cucumber world so to actually use
cucumber world you actually need to pass
it in as dash dash world parameters
inside the cucumber js arguments
but what we want to do is we want to
have the ability to have customized
config for our hosts our pages our
element mappings all those key things
that make up a sort of world-class
automation framework that can do all the
things you would expect to do in any web
application so we need to pass that
hence why we needed to basically have
our cucumber jack ts because this is a
typescript framework as you can see
there on the right
but this is the trick right
so in our in our index see now in our
cucumber.js this would sit basically in
your root directory
it will actually just exports and
require dot slash dist right
and so when we actually run this
framework it's going to look in the disk
and it's not going to find the cucumber
ts
that's right it's going to find the
cucumber.js
and that is exactly what we need so we
can write our framework in typescript
and unlock all the beautiful benefits of
typescript but when it comes to
compilation we're going to have this bad
boy running in javascript which is going
to play beautifully with the cucumber js
runner and get us in a position where we
can run our framework
as is
and and and that's again something that
was a big challenge right there was no
documentation for this this is something
we had to work out as a team and thank
god we'd ran those proof of concepts
right because we had those developers on
board we were we had these questions we
could bring in our best engineers they
were part of the architecture they were
part of the poc they'd they had that
buy-in we talked about so they were on
the journey and they helped us come up
with this solution
and by leveraging cucumber world
parameters we can then pass in our host
configuration page configuration and
element mappings on our runtime so
segregated between each scenario so just
on the left there this is what you call
your world.ts and this is the default
file that basically the the cucumber
world all the initialization and the
constructor sits within and it's
actually where you define the things
that you want to have as segregated
global configuration now you can see
we've got global config and we've got
global variables
so to quickly explain what they are
think global config that's where you're
going to have your pages you know your
home page your login page you can have
your route there your rejects you're
going to match it up you're going to
have your hosts you know are we going to
our local host are we going to our
production.com.ou
host you know and then you're going to
have your elements you know your login
button your submit button this is where
all this stuff's going to be managed and
we do that using dot jsons and i'll show
you that in a minute as well
finally we have our global variables and
this is where we can do things like
store eg a stored value you know what
about those tests where you don't know
what the balance is going to be you know
maybe you're running these on production
as well and you want to
store your balance at the start of the
test and assert that it's five dollars
less after you do something that's where
you're spending five dollars
by using this approach that will be
segregated data
for this scenario so you won't have any
issue running that scenario 20 times at
the same time doing all different types
of updates everything's going to work
because we've put in the hard work to
initialize cucumber world and have that
segregated context
we can then leverage config.jsons to
create a set of host config page config
and mapping config and that's what we
just talked about so this is where you
have this really clean folder structure
right so you've basically got e2e config
mappings in there you've got all your
element mappings so you've got your home
page mappings maybe it's your header
logo maybe it's your sign in button and
then you've got your comment json right
because we're dealing with single page
applications you're going to have
element mappings that sit across
multiple things each of your headers and
your footers and then you're going to
have your host.json this is again where
you're going to have things like your
local host your production urls because
you want to run this in localhost you
want to run it on multiple in test
environments you want to run production
right
and then you've got your pages and
that's where you define all the
different pages within the application
itself so we can navigate around the
application or jump straight to a part
of our application or or even just know
where to draw our page elements from on
the left there you can basically see in
that index.ts remember converted to js
on runtime we've got all the things
around getting that json out of those
files based on a host path or a url's
path that will define an environment
variable in our common.nbc
so then we can actually leverage
config.jsons to create a set of host
configs page configs at runtime so
you've got your pages.json you've got
your home you set it to your slash right
home page usually it's just a dead route
it's just a slash then you've got your
host.json simple enough we'll run this
on our local host which is our http
localhost 3000 we've got our first
element identifier we want to interact
with it's our contacts header data id
contacts that's what's in our html
that's how we'll reference this element
and finally what is this all console log
well it produces an object that looks a
lot like this so it tells us that we've
got a common.json a home.json and in
that we've got our header logo and our
contacts header and as you can imagine
we'll be able to soon draw from that
using the parameters we passed through
with cucumber
so let's finish out our automation test
let's get this bad boy up and running so
let's go back to our cucumber scenario
now we've got our homepage up we've
navigated to our homepage we've spun up
the framework we've got cucumber world
initialized we're about to hit our first
page hallelujah just hit our homepage
congratulations let's move on to the
next step so we want to go and the
header logo should be displayed so we
just want to assert that the home page
has a header logo so let's go ahead and
step into that step
[Music]
so what we can do here is we can
actually leverage the config.jsons
to create a set of host configs page
configs at runtime once again and we do
that because it's already initialized at
runtime it's it's actually initialized
within the framework it's there but
we're actually going to pass it via
scenario world so you'll see their async
function this scenario world that's
going to draw in that object we just saw
in the console log directly into this
step definition for that scenario
completely segregated once again
so as you can see we then log out what
we want to log out from a debugging
perspective but this is a cool line and
this can work across any step for the
rest of our framework const element
identifier equals get element locator
page element key global config so we go
off and retrieve our element locator
based on that parameter hit a logo and
where did we just see that we saw it in
our console log because that was what we
drawed down at the start when the
framework ran and we stored in our
global config from from our json files
we also have our custom wait for
function there and we retrieve elements
true or false and assert if the element
is visible accordingly we decided to not
use playwright tests for those wondering
why we decided to use native assertions
and it's because the default playwright
test library as it did not work
perfectly with cucumber so this is
really interesting as well right like it
has support for cucumber but because
playwright's still sort of in its infamy
it's still a relatively new framework
it's not perfectly set up for it yet so
we actually found that using native
assertions was a better approach
we also discovered that by using negate
it would enable us to have our step do
two things instead of one so our step is
actually the blast should not be
displayed or the buyer should be
displayed
it can actually do both which is really
cool
then we retrieve our element identifier
based on our cucumber header logo so
this is just the logic behind that get
element located as you can see it's
really simple stuff look you'd think
that would be doing a lot of complex
code but it's not it's literally just
looking in that page elements mapping
object we saw a console logged out
before it's going hey which page are we
on okay we're on the home page so we
need to go in and then grab our element
identifier from our home.json really
simple stuff but really clever what it's
doing
so next we actually retrieve our page
based on our current url so this was
actually something amazing that was done
by one of our top engineers so
we originally were setting our page id
via the cucumber you know given i am on
the home page if i click the login
button then i'm on the login page this
engineer was like why aren't you doing
this dynamically why aren't you setting
a regex in your pages.json and then
creating a function that can actually go
off grab your url match it against your
pages and tell you what page you're on
so we removed that entire need to have
that step to tell us what page we're on
to determine where we get our actual
element mappings that was there for us
we created this function that literally
goes off and retrieves the page for on
and stores that in the framework and
allows us to pull down our mapping our
element identifiers this was so cool and
just another backtracking benefit of
that proof of concept getting the team
on board those showcases that passion
we're bringing and that determination to
build something that's never really been
built before
so to get element function as you can
imagine so this would sit in our html
behavior and this is where the majority
of the differentiation would happen eg
between a playwright or selenium
framework this is where we actually use
playwright to get element and as you can
see there we're just finding an element
otherwise we'd return now in that
function
all right
there you go so and the header logo
should be displayed
we can use this sim single step to
assert on any visible or not visible
visible element on our website and if
you're thinking wait you could use this
on any website you're absolutely right
so you could copy and paste this entire
framework into your web project right
now
update that element identifier in the
mappings update the pages in the config
so any json updates we're talking about
copy and paste this step and this will
work for you as well and that's really a
really genius part of this framework
so let's finish it out so now our final
step for our scenario then the contacts
header should contain the contacts let's
go ahead and step in
so notice now we can leverage all our
existing html behavior functions to
serve an entirely new purpose right so
we're using that negate again
we're using that get element locator
exactly the same function
we're using our weight for selector and
we've got a new get element text which
basically will sit in that html behavior
thus giving us new functionality by
using playwright functions right
but isn't that amazing we've basically
got a completely different step one was
asserting against an element now we're
asserting against text
but we've literally had to add no code
we've got a new step but we haven't
actually had to add any new code really
to our functionality except that get
element text so let's go and have a look
at that so our get element text function
to retire of our text
pretty standard again it just goes off
uses playwright.text content and
retrieves our text from our element
but a bing bada boom the so the contact
header should contain the text contacts
up and running working as expected and
we've just created another step that
could assert on any text in our
application
or any text on any application in the
world as long as we update that mappings
in in that config folder
so let's review some of these key
concepts we've just introduced because
we've done a bit so we've got cucumber
world so we leveraged cucumber world to
us enable segregated page host elements
mappings for each scenario across our
automation suite we introduced babel for
ts to javascript conversion so we
leveraged babel to enable cucumber js
customization while still being able to
build our automation framework with
typescript check we initialized our
mappings on runtime we are setting all
our pages hosts and element mappings as
objects we can easily match via our
cucumber parameters
dynamic pages so we created a function
that determines what page we are on
actually from our pages.json based on
the url that the framework actually
pulls down as part of that step
we don't even have to tell it what page
we're on it tells us and then it knows
where to draw down those page element
attributes based on what the jason's
called whether it's home.json or
login.json
generic steps we create generic steps
and reusable cucumber steps that can be
used for the same purpose across both
interactions and assertions so you can
use these steps
across the entire application so you can
get to a point where you've got hundreds
of tests for your web application
potentially automated from less than 50
step definitions
we have reusable functions so we created
generic and reusable functions that can
be leveraged across the entire framework
that service the functions of many steps
so
success we have built a framework that
is so architecturally sound we can
literally substitute out playwright for
selenium
not lose any tests not lose any step
definitions or functions and here's a
working actual example of both so
we actually created a small bare bones
react application um at bunnings um a
few of us got together and built this as
part of a sort of hack day it's been
amazing actually so it's literally just
a real bare bones react application it's
got some of the major components you'd
expect to see inside the playground
but what's really cool about it right is
that if you've got a test suite of like
50 tests that validate through the
entire test application you're really
validating the entire framework works
because this framework is so
generic in architecture and can be
copied and pasted from project to
project
it's actually architecturally sufficient
enough that you could create a single
framework and you could actually
write the features on each project and
have a single common framework between
multiple projects
and that's something we did at tabcorp
with a similar approach where we had
over 3000 automation tests across 16 web
applications running off a single
framework that was maintained by a
technology team of over 100
at bunnings this is a new framework you
know we've got it up and running now for
bunnings we've got it up and running for
a new system called hybris so we're in
the infamy of kind of getting that
common framework going across both
applications now this uh this framework
architecturally has has just gone leaps
and bounds and again it goes back to
that poc i think you know when we we did
the version of it at tab and that was
using protractor and typescript no
actually sorry it was using cucumber
protractor and javascript
we did it predominantly as a test team
with some additional help from
developers is especially as we work
together to build out the suite
but um at bunnings it's it's been
hand-in-hand with the engineers and
we've seen the dividends from that
uh just on the right we've also got the
playwright version of the framework
running as well
i decided not to include the cypress one
i just wanted to show you that we did
get this up and running in multiple
frameworks so again cyprus selenium and
playwright
so yeah
on the next slide as well
i just wanted to also show you um the
structural um the files folder structure
and show you how it's the exact same
because that's the thing right it can
literally be the exact same you can have
the exact same
in features you can have the exact same
reporter step definition setup and
support now under that code what's
different as we saw there'll be some
minor changes in the hooks as we
initialize our suite whether it's
running on a driver or if it's running
on the page
you're going to have some minor
differences around the world because
we're going to have potentially
different browsers we use you know in
selenium you're going to have chrome and
safari you know in playwright you're
going to have chromium and webkit for
example
the steps themselves exactly the same
literally no difference
the support functions that's that's
where the real change is right although
you've got the exact same code one is
going to be calling selenium functions
and one is going to be calling
playwright functions
so key successes just to round this out
so we saw increased collaboration we saw
significant increases in collaboration
across our team using the framework
approach that was easy to use and
enabled all our team members to be
contributors
we saw massive improvements in code
quality since the code was so minimal
and generic we found maintaining code
quality through collaboration and pull
request review to be very easy and
straightforward
many tests from minimal code this
framework approach has enabled us to
create hundreds of automation tests
across multiple applications with very
little code less time coding and more
time adding automation tests
leveraging across multiple projects we
are able to literally copy and paste
this framework into a new project then
update our hosts and pages
and element mapping json files for the
application and have a fully function
functional automation framework we can
just get started copying and pasting
those steps right away
key challenges selling the engineers on
cucumber many engineers have had bad
experiences with cucumber in the past
you know maybe they've had debates about
how it should be used or if bdd's the
right way or not what we found was those
showcases and that poc solved all those
problems the engineers saw that we
wanted to use cucumber for its
architectural benefits
for its enablement benefits and they got
fully on board and were very supportive
and then of course proving the upfront
effort is worth it you know as you can
see with this framework approach there's
a bit of upfront effort right like
you've got to build out that kind of you
know actually getting cucumber world
working for example like we saw you know
we had to overcome some hurdles we had
to build out those
initial step definitions but of course
once you get over that hump once you've
paid down that initial debt you're over
the hump and you're literally in that
low code no code scenario where you're
basically able to just add cucumber
steps and build out those tests
so
you might be saying well how can i learn
about this framework well fortunately i
have gone off and it's been about 100
plus hours or more developing a course
on udemy
and it's a best-selling course which is
fantastic the community really seemed to
love the course it's got a very high
rating as well and you can actually
learn as we say how to build a
world-class automation framework in
either cucumber playwright or typescript
or cucumber selenium typescript so
please check it out
we offer full support as well so you
know if you want to join up we'll invite
you straight away to our slack we're
pretty much happy to help you know we
love this stuff i'm a tester through and
through i love this community i'll be
your direct point of contact as your
help and guidance for that course as
well
let's go on that journey together
a little bit about testing talks
conference so you know i established
testing talks conference in 2019 and
what it's all about is similar to
selenium conf bringing amazing people
together amazing people from our
community working hands-on doing amazing
things but on top of that it's also
about swag fun games prizes it's shaping
up to be a massive event we've got some
incredible sponsors on board some that
are obviously joined in with this
conference as well from browser stack to
aptly tools to lambda test
and it's going to be a big day the way
we think of it is we want it to be a
party for our community a day the
community a day the community can look
forward to so please join us it's going
to be an amazing day amazing speakers
and so much fun
finally let's connect on linkedin you
know um i love to connect with community
i'm pretty much available around the
clock to have a chat have a yarn have a
coffee if you're in melbourne
definitely add me up you know i live and
breathe this stuff and i love the
community i love testing so go ahead and
connect and i'll definitely connect back
thanks everyone any questions
so we can see some questions in q a
now let's check that out
is bdd implemented in the whole team or
is just the qa team using it this is a
fantastic question so
we are using this across the team now so
when you think about bdd
traditionally you're thinking about you
know the way we define our business
requirements you know given i am on the
when i do that then i see that um we
don't use bdd in its traditional sense
so you won't actually see our test cases
read as a story per se we use it for
that generic step definition
architecture you would have seen
throughout this presentation so it's a
little bit different but we definitely
follow the idea of readable tests just
not for the traditional purpose of bdd
now the developers are definitely across
it because they're across the whole
process but they're not doing ddd
they're they're using cucumber for its
architectural benefits and and and easy
story writing and
the enablement of the team so it's a
little bit different
uh no question but enjoyed listening
full of energy did you take a breath
good question i did take a breath i
should have drunk more water but i was
too excited to present here today thanks
for that my friend
um what about dashboard in playwright um
is that uh the playwright inspector or
the the is are you asking if there's a
dashboard equivalent similar to cyprus
and playwright i'm not quite sure
i'll speak to both so basically um i
found playwright inspector really good
it's pretty cool it's like this tool
that basically with a simple environment
variable set will spin up a debugger
that you can basically view as the test
runs and shows you what elements you're
hitting and what it's doing in the html
i feel like it's still in its early days
it's a little bit um temperamental like
you'll be running a test and it'll just
shut down and you'll have to run your
test to see it again but it's super
beneficial overall and we definitely
teach it in the course as well because
we see the benefits of that
as far as dashboards in playwright
you know we're using cucumber so we use
the cucumber html reporter which is sort
of the go-to reporter um
for cucumber so we didn't use any sort
of playwright dashboard per se also it
doesn't have a dashboard like that of
the equivalent of cypress either it's
really just a test reporter nonetheless
really cool stuff
though awesome i think that's all the
questions
okay that's another question
one more if you want i think we're
outside up to you up to you
okay yep you can take
yeah i've got time okay can you compare
performance with selenium and playwright
playwright came out ahead um so
if you run our exact framework on our
bare bones react application with
playwright and you run the same
framework with selenium running on the
exact same architecture like you just
saw
running on the same browser binary
we actually saw about a 10 second
improvement overall across the 50 tests
when running in playwright so minor
improvements
however
very similar to be honest
i found them both extremely beneficial
and that's why i did a course on both of
them i think it comes down to personal
preference the only thing i will say is
playwright handles long forms a hell of
a lot better still than selenium like i
still found with the selenium framework
we had to add a lot of those scroll to
elements just to get us over the hump
but generally speaking both really great
frameworks and selenium selenium 4.0 has
has come a long way highly rated and i
think it's back back it's definitely
back other stories written in gherkin so
you just have just to implement it in
the framework or are your adoptions in
the scripts unnecessary
i guess the story is written in goku so
when we write our business requirements
we work with our bas to produce them in
sort of a given and when equivalent but
they don't break down the steps into
generic step definitions like we act we
actually add them in our tests so we
haven't looked at aligning our our tests
our tests perfectly with our business
requirements yet it's just not something
we've we've endeavored to do and i'm not
sure if we will i think the process is
really working right now and i think the
testers and developers are happy to
let a little bit of exploration happen
when they write their tests rather than
just trying to replicate the ba
requirements coming through on the cards
and thanks cameron for sharing your
experience with us today thanks everyone
[Music]